so a very natural question to ask I'm so
glad so an Austin natural maybe a real
christian ask anyway is is well if you
can play this game VR and say that these
two sets are equal in size can you
always do this hmm so here's what we
going to do I am going to try and play
the same game with the real numbers and
then show you why it doesn't work okay
so um quicker is you know what what
makes a real number different through a
rational number what kinds of numbers
are real but they're not rational yeah
oh you're thinking of you're thinking of
the difference between real and like
complex okay big things simpler we know
what rational numbers are what does it
mean when I was not rational we know
that these numbers are right here's an
example okay 1 1 & 2 oh look it's not a
ratio between any two integers it's its
own theme okay now this is very
important you actually um I'm actually
gonna get so month
audience-participation here I think
there are 12 digits when you're
calculating your space so I looked at
first of all people who have calculators
to get them out and stand at the front
okay so if you get a calculator so I've
got one here's a whole bunch of real
numbers okay and by the way just for the
record yes you could totally just make
up numbers as you go okay but the point
is what were you trying to do is write
down well we can't write that all of
them but just imagine that we could
write so you know dot dot dot and it
just keeps on going forever now my game
before was to say for look okay here's
your real numbers okay I'm just gonna
match these all up to what am i doing
integers okay I can do that
there are problems look they will just
go down the line like this so I'll make
this matched up with one
and two and three and full and so on
okay
it's your like what's the big deal it
looks like I can use the same logic and
I can prove that these are the same ah
except there's a problem there's a
problem and I'm gonna show it to you
with another diagonal watch this okay so
our assumption was that this list of
real numbers if it went on forever has
all of the real numbers on it okay but
I'm about to prove to you that no matter
how long this list Dory's this list can
go on forever you still be missing a
number watch this
I need some space what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to form a diagonal here I'm
gonna make a new real number right and
I'm gonna try and show you why even if
this list goes on forever the real
number I make up will be different to
every single one that you write down and
there can be an infinite number of you
might end up watch this I'm just going
to start with zero point cuz everyone
Hofstede turned into peer pressure okay
well I'm gonna do so let's just start
with this first number here remember
what am I trying to do I'm trying to
make up a real number that isn't on your
list so I'm just gonna say welcome let's
look at this first decimal place here
okay all I'm gonna do is in my
manufactured number I'll just make sure
my decimal for this first place is
different to that one I'm gonna make it
same let's just add one three okay now
automatically this I don't I don't care
what the rest of it is okay this number
is already different to the one that's
first on the list so far so good you're
like well there's a lot more numbers on
this to going it's alright I have
infinity on my side only on the second
number I look at the next decimal place
and I say well I don't wanna match up
with that one either I'll just make it
different I'll just add one this number
no matter what comes after here or here
or here will always be different than
both of these numbers does that make
sense
I've already got this comment this point
of difference may yell I bought out the
phone number well it's cool I'll just
make sure the decimal place is also
different I'm just adding number one and
I'll make sure it's different to this on
line one
make sure is different to this one
that's my last one now have a look with
me this number that I just written up
the top in green this number is clearly
different to every number that you have
written on the board and that's that's
kind of obvious right because there
aren't that many members of it but
here's the thing your list which goes on
forever right
my numbers gonna be different to all of
them even though your list goes on
forever I've got a number that you
missed you remember this is all about
matching up things right actually not
matching our matching up I found a whole
band at all I can find another hole
instead of adding one I can just take
away one from every digit right that'll
be two subsonic one one six one nine
zero two six zero five look this number
isn't on your lists either right in fact
I can come up with an infinite number of
numbers that aren't on your infinite
list it's a lot of holes so therefore
with a different kind of diagonal what I
proven is that even though you'll this
goes forever like the number of integers
that's how many of these you have
because it goes on forever right will
always be less than the number of real
numbers okay now this is really
mind-bending right because how are all
the numbers this is why I asked you for
to put zero point on front of your thing
right all of these numbers all these
numbers are between zero and one aren't
they there are between zero and one and
I just said that all of these numbers
are more than all of the counting
numbers so that means there are more
numbers between zero and one
then there are from one two three four
five forever there are more numbers
nestled in that little gap there then
there are in the whole list that's weird
that's weird now to talk about these two
different kinds of infinity it's a bit
weird it's like you know infinity is
less than infinity that's a bit strange
so we need to your language for this
right Marc Marquez are here on this
Infini over here because it comes from
counting one two three four we call this
a countable infinity but yes it's an
infinity and it goes from but I can
count it I can just go on to the right
and if I kept forever I'll match up one
two one
this guy this guy this is way bigger
that this is you can't counter the Khan
Academy no matter how long we count I'll
always come up with more that aren't on
your list this is called and uncountable
infinite okay
so you can say things up sips are
countably infinite or unaccountably
infinite and that tells you how much
bigger one is than the other
now the real question to bend your mind
is if you call this like this is not a
proper notation by the way but you're
like well okay countable right is less
than all new counts moves me but how
much less well how much bigger is is
this than this you're like oh you don't
think 10 times bigger than two it's five
times bigger
right how much bigger is this then this
is it a counter or infinity or is it an
uncountable so anyway there you go yeah
what's the point about this right this
is all just to put some more meat on the
bones of when you say oh yeah you know
infinity this infinity that well which
infinity do you mean and there are other
kinds these are just two of the
infinities how many kinds of infinities
do you think there are I
is there an infinite number infinity is
it a countably infinite number of
infinite one can you get me so yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna start I'm gonna stop